[Music]
advertising is particularly good at
attaching emotions to brands
terrific example from years back is a
car called the renault clio years ago
they launched with an advertising
campaign featuring a couple of daft
french people papa nicole
the whole idea of that ad was supposed
to be that the renault clear is a
terrifically easy car to drive however
when you look at that ad what you're
looking at is two people flirting being
terrifically sexy and of course what
that does is result in you thinking the
renault clio is a terrifically sexy
little car and lots of people want to be
sexy the result the most successful car
launch ever in the uk
better communication are all the
twiddly bits the music the characters
the setting the storyline anything
that's not actually to do with what
you're
telling people the interesting thing
about
meta communication
is that we are programmed not to be able
to unprocess it once it's exposed to us
we've got it here's a good example the
famous apple 1984 ad
was shown once on um midnight in 1983
and once in the super bowl
in 1984 and yet that ad is known
practically all around the world the ad
is the girl
running down this aisle with all these
zombie-like people
and she hurls the mallet through the
screen
and of course the message in that ad is
very simple the world is being dominated
in that
era by ibm and apple is going to break
out of that era that idea of apple being
the defender of the people the defender
of freedom
of course reflected into steve jobs who
became the epitome of the defender of
the people
which means people who buy apple
computers and in most cases
astonishingly even though that ad would
never have actually been seen by them on
air
they know about this ad
and they feel apple is a terrific
company
and in that respect once you get a
reputation like that established
it's there forever
there's a
company called huawei who've recently
launched an ad featuring a little
creature called the gnu being
photographed
and the guy who's photographing the gnu
um looks at his photograph he imagines
what's going to happen to the little gnu
it's going to be captured it's going to
be put in a zoo it's going to have
things thrown at it
so
he decides not to take the photograph
and the message is with who are we
you can
be your own judge
of morality
what absolute nonsense i mean huawei's a
phone doesn't allow you to do anything
but emotionally very appealing
[Music]
how do you stop your emotions being
influenced by advertising
well in my book there's only two ways to
do
one is just don't watch any advertising
the other way
curiously enough is to watch the ad very
carefully is to look at it and to say
what are you trying to do
what are you trying to influence what's
really behind this hat if i see this
little furry animal
in the woods what's there for is it
there
to make me feel good about this brand
yeah of course it is and by doing that
you can do something called counter
arguing we're not used to
counter-arguing the emotion in
advertising
but if you look at the ads
if you if you look at the emotive
content in the ads if you listen to the
music you can say
i know what you're trying to do so
emotionally you can counter argue that
ad
of course
it probably won't work
but at least you can feel you're
slightly more in control of your life
than the advertisers are
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video